I'm looking for a husband and you're
looking for a wife who's pickier
typically I think it's roughly equal
really that's so interesting but the
reason why is because you guys get all
your information from dating apps where
the numbers are super skewed but if you
go into any school all the boys are
dating All the Girls when there are
environments where men and women are
together I would actually agree on
college campuses because it's similar
there's like a select group of men that
tend to do very well because you said
men do very well is that a select group
of men like athletes one athlete is not
dating five women they might have sex
but that's why I say it's important to
distinguish sex between relationships